oh you said to your grandma it's like
looking forward to watch you yes on
YouTube right yes you wanna say hi to
your grandma hi Grandmom shout out hi
I'm Ria today I've been challenged to
take out popular food and make it fancy
you did it today I have a special guest
she is a big Makey fancy fan Sierra hi
Ria thank you for having me yeah thank
you for coming she flew from Atlanta
it's across the country it's a big deal
why am I making fancy today today you
are making fancy a Starbucks lemon loaf
I love lemon pounder cake it's like a
good little treat and I love lemon
flavored things I also feel like this is
already fancy that's what I thought too
it's a little fancy it's a little bit it
smells so good
it's all good I like this it's not too
sweet the texture is very soft and moist
I think it would be really unexpected
and really cool if you made something
Savory out of this challenge accepted
but you have to help me that sounds good
co-pilot challenge accepted all right
make it fancy
all right here's what I got ricotta
cheese parsley pea shoots basil dragon
fruit powder celery heavy cream butter
edible flowers parmesan cheese yellow
onion
chives thyme carrots eggs lobster tails
and black truffle from the palm tree I
got semolina flour lemons double ditto
flour bay leaves garlic and shallots all
right let's get started make it fancy so
the first step we're gonna do a surgery
we are going to remove icing from the
pound cake you know it's a very serious
surgery it's very
did you ever play Operation no why it's
not it's a game and there's this little
guy and he has these like random objects
in his body and you have to remove them
with like tweezers but if the tweezers
touch anything but the little object he
gets like electrocuted sounds horrifying
it's a kid's game so it's fine it's a
kids game our surgery is almost done
you're gonna just put this in a bowl
like just break it we're gonna use it
for later and I'm going to dehydrate
this pound okay until crispy do you have
any guests so far what am I making no
but I feel like we're having a little
bread crumb Croton moment with this we
will see we will yeah we are cooking
together but Sierra has no idea no I'm
going to put this in a dehydrator and we
are moving on to next step all right so
it has been dehydrated can you tell no
it looks the same three two one crush or
not it's crunchy though crunchy do you
want to try it
hmm that is really good it's tasty
reminds me of like the lemon Girl Scout
cookies yeah I'm gonna put this in a
spice grinder have you used spice
grinder before I don't know so you're
gonna just hold the top and push the
black bottom and now I'm going to sift
all right now we have lemony Pound Cake
Powder and let's go next step we have
lobsters I would not think about a lemon
pound cake and lobsters together so now
we're gonna cook lobster and the lobster
Cooks kind of quickly indicator is it
turns bright red so it takes about four
to five minutes you don't want to
overcook it it's become like very labery
I'm gonna give you a lobster fact the
largest lobster ever caught weighed 44
pounds
it was three and a half
no I'm like that sounds delicious okay
so it's bright red and we're gonna chalk
with ice water so I will stop cooking
right so we have instant pot and we have
some aromatic we have onion celery
carrot and I'm going to saute do you
have any idea what I'm doing I have a
sense that we're gonna make a lobster
stock
it's a good guess you know I'm gonna
saute how do you use instant pot before
I'm not it's like really great tall kind
of shortcut the time and we're gonna
saute until milpoa is soft I think this
is great all the vegetables are soft and
I'm going to use salt kind of helps
cooking process faster because it draws
moisture and now this is the lobster
shell okay we roast it in an oven and
it's very has a strong smell it's like
constant traded a lobster but it's going
to in a stock oh I got it right all
right so now Sierra the pound cake yes
I'm intrigued this feels strange so the
pound of cake kind of helps thickens the
stock all that our stem has very very
good flavor especially it's good for
making stocks yeah it's the parmesan
good job
Water Bay Leaf black pepper it looks
like we just throwing everything in the
pot and like hope for the best but trust
me they see it's gonna be very tasty we
are going to pressure cook this about 45
minutes all right so we have double zero
flour and semolina flour and dehydrated
Starbucks lemon pounder cake flour can
you put all the flour into this box
nice and then last but not least the
lemon pound cake powder and I have whole
eggs olive oil dragon fruit powder I
chose it because your favorite color is
pink yes this makes it super pretty oh
that's exciting can you see more sister
now I'm going to make a well so I'm
going to pour to look like a volcano can
you put egg yolk nice it's kind of
pretty and I'm going to mix try not to
break the well yet and slowly in
Coldplay flour oh see you don't want to
happen okay thank you do you want to try
Okay so just like yeah can you guess
what we are making right now pasta yes
have you made pasta from scratch no it's
flavor intensive but it is fun to make
yes do you want to try that's great
create is the dragon fruit powder and
the pasta change the way it tastes
we only use like a little bit like not
too much amount and the dragon fruit
powder is like very mild I think we are
almost there all right so we have to
rest the dough when we walk with dough
it becomes very very tough so we have to
relax the glue down and then we have
more things to do okay
so I have ricotta parmesan cheese lemon
zest and our older friend so I'm gonna
put everything in a food processor
parmesan cheese lemon zest salt and I
see I'm gonna brand I'm going to put
everything in the ball do you cook a lot
at home sometimes I probably bake more
than I cook well it's your favorite
thing to bake the craziest cake I ever
made I was in an edible cookie dough
face a chocolate cake a layer of edible
cookie dough and then a layer of
chocolate cake a little bit of a cookie
dough a little layer of chocolate cake
chocolate frosting and then like cookie
crumbs and it was a lot okay but it was
a lot so we have ricotta cheese mix
right here can you add the herbs yes
nice we didn't put in a food processor
because sometimes fresh herbs get brewed
you know interesting there's a pasta
piece yes a lobster piece there's a
stock piece and now there's a ricotta
piece you've lost me
looks good this is only the beginning
okay
so this is the pasta dough we rested and
I'm going to cut in a quarter very nice
we are going to start with number one
I'm going to go up until seven so can
you start catching my dog
I want to make it perfect rectangle so
I'm going to fold it and I'm going to
put
the last one we are at number seven
super thin but delicate we did it
and beautiful yeah I love the color it's
gonna look so good all right so this is
the pasta we rolled out we gonna cut out
in a cookie cutter all my strength into
it perfect yeah yeah this is the last
one
oh my gosh oh no
nobody see it
wait a second that was very satisfying
let's get fancy fancy time
foreign
and I'm gonna pipe I don't want to
overfill so maybe this much when you are
piping don't squeeze from here squeeze
from Top This is just a support okay and
squeeze from the top and you kind of
want to do Straight yep that's good we
are going to close so you're going to
use water so just wet around the edge
and then you're going to push and hold
just close so I paint the edges and then
push the middle like make the corners
touch yeah yeah yeah yeah cute yeah I
think that I thought the lobster was
going to be in the ravioli my mind is
still thinking and let's cook them off
but actually I don't know the name of
this pasta because it's a special shape
do you want to guess you know it's gonna
Sound Italian this is make it fancy we
couldn't just do tortellini but the
fancy version this is actually capiletti
is it it's just an Italian though yeah
oh you said your grandma it's like
looking forward to watch you yes on
YouTube right yes you wanna say hi to
your grandma hi Grandmom shout out we
cook all the
bloody capillary when you're cooking at
home if you have to cook the pasta ahead
you can drizzle some olive oil so it
doesn't stick together oh okay yeah it's
very convenient tasty hack we still have
lobster to cook so can you add olive oil
just like a swirl can you add shallot so
we're gonna saute shallots first okay
put Garlic tend to choose Brown too
quickly I like cooking with shallots
because shallots are fancy I think it's
less sharp than onion all right so it's
nice and soft can you add garlic and
saute until fragrant and it starts
smelling like really nice now you want
to add Lobster stock because it's the
stock we cooked in a pressure cooker and
we strain it and we are going to bring
it to a boil what did the parmesan
cheese and the stock do cheese rind it's
usually gets thrown away but it gives
mommy it gives like nice savory deep
flavor okay let's stop learning
something new today yeah good question
so it looks good and I'm going to strain
I just want to have an essence of all
the flavor this is a strained broth back
into the pot and we're gonna put cream
and lemon zest kind of give a nice
sharpness gotta reinforce the lemon
pound cake yeah exactly and parmesan
cheese and I'm gonna put butter now once
the butter is melted and sauce is nice
and creamy you are going to put the
lobster Lobster is already cooked so we
are just kind of warming up it's like
very elegant it really is it's fancy
it's fancy we reduced sauce a little bit
so it's very nice and thick and we're
gonna start plating lemon zest pea soup
and now I'm gonna ship truffle do you
want to add edible flour and we are done
oh
Starbucks lemon loaf capillary with
lobster super fancy it looks fancy and I
think it's really unexpected yes that's
I wanted to hear we're gonna do taste
test we usually have a guests to taste
our creation since you helped me today
is there anybody you want to surprise I
would love to surprise my cousin Shelly
okay Shelly all right
funny seeing you here do you want to
open the cover yes I do all right
oh my goodness that looks so good so we
made a Starbucks lemon loaf capoleti
with lobster it sounds very delicious
and yes try it let's try okay I'm super
excited I am too well that is delicious
oh it's so good I like how it's really
really lemony and bright I like the
plating it's very hard to see can you
guess how did we incorporate this is
hard I feel like I'm assuming part of
the sauce like it tastes lemony I'm
curious about what the actual pasta
shell is made out of so I feel like it
might be a little bit in there too
especially because it was like bread I
think you've nailed it basically maybe I
should be a cook okay did we make
Starbucks lemon fancy absolutely with
the Truffle and everything this is one
of the fancier meals I've had
we have one last thing to do three two
one make it fancy
[Music]
thank you